[Music]
joining me now John Radcliffe former
Director of National Intel John your
response tonight to what's unfolding the
DHS is basically announcing to all the
people who got away and didn't fill out
the little piece of paper that a
Crackdown is coming this is this is just
theater is it not
yeah Laura it's either you know colossal
stupidity or as you intimated in your
opening it's deliberate I mean this is
an Administration that has opened every
door and every window uh as you as you
outlined with Charlie hurt there the
from day one the remain in Mexico policy
the agreements with Mexico Guatemala
Honduras El Salvador stop building the
wall all of the things that were
effective during the Trump campaign they
all went away day one the only semblance
of a of a firewall if you will the only
thing that was making a bad situation
um not Beyond Comprehension was title 42
uh the policy that has allowed
2.7 million illegals over the last three
years to be immediately expelled from
the country before they can seek Asylum
and now on Thursday Joe Biden's going to
take that last line of defense away and
what's going to happen is just an
absolute disaster in every respect
including from a national security
perspective I mean estimates Laura are
that we're going to have about a hundred
thousand uh illegals crossing a week
every week
and with that population you're going to
see uh you know an increase in drug
crimes gun crimes sex crimes violent
crimes and even the well-meaning people
that don't have intentions of causing
harm to Americans are going to burden
with you know food shelter medicine the
the the burdens on our communities are
really unfathomable and well John all I
think I think you're right I think this
is all part of a Biden Administration
plan and strategy over the last two and
a half years but it's going to get
people think it's bad it's going to get
worse happening on Thursday well look
you can drive you know a couple miles
from where we're broadcasting tonight
and see tent after tent after tent after
tent
in the shadow of the nation's capital
okay so we have our Capitol building our
Dome and then homeless tents within you
know four four 450 yards
and it's growing
and this is what Americans voted for to
exacerbate an already bad problem in our
country with homelessness it's insane by
the way Texas Congressman Tony Gonzalez
told the New York Post that he learned
while speaking to the Guatemalan
president that there are 80 000 illegals
who are making their way through
Guatemala right now and and that figure
prompted him to call the bite
Administration to share the information
he said I called the White House and no
one's picking up
I mean meanwhile they're they're talking
to Colombia
right how does that make any sense
unless this is part of the plan
right it doesn't this is Joe Biden's
America and it's going to increasingly
uh become apparent to to people the the
only thing that I can tell you Laura
that it's getting so bad
um the Biden My orcas plan is that even
Democrats now are calling them liars and
saying there is no plan and that they
are the Progressive Democrats who were
railing against title 42 are now saying
do something because they know what's
about to happen uh and the chaos and the
destruction and unfortunately the uh the
death and injury to Americans that are
going to happen uh in the coming months
yeah well Urban America that's been let
down by the Democrats election after
election and lied to this is one of the
biggest lies ever told because it's
going to hurt Urban America and urban
schools the most so they're going to pay
the most for all this John thank you for
your perspective tonight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else